[Music]
so my goal this tournament five month
gambit is to play gambit
every single game
uh starting with a hillbilly
oh no my pawn
thank you square mountain
also thank you reuter nfl
so this is a um
the hillbilly against the caro khan
opponent wants to trap my bishop i'll
just play a4
and the idea is after takes queen a5 the
threatening sum
f7 pawn
thank you laser po
the prime sub
yeah very often this will be played
and i might
i might take but i might play f3
depending what black does
oh
i have this move
i also have f3 immediately
i'll play f3
yeah this might only be a a temporary
gambit
because the pawns attack three times and
pinned to the queen
queen's not defended
if bishop c5
then maybe 92
hit the queen
i think my next move will be 92 and then
eventually regain the pawn good luck in
the tourney
oh thank you
mr wk
and welcome back tommy triathletes
something for half a year
oh that's a good move
oh my pawn structure is going to be in
shambles
almost like gamut again
no i should probably play d3
so generally
when you have a single bishop of a
certain color you want your pawns on
opposite color of the bishop
the structure complements my bishop
maybe my knight can find happiness
oh that's a good move i have this in
king c2
defending the pawn
so i'm probably slightly worse here but
game will carry on
i'm realizing my knight wants to be on
c4
b5 was potential square but didn't wanna
suffer with triple pawns
i'm threatening a fork i fix my
structure
now it's actually not so bad
with all my pawns on light squares
avoid the bishop trade
yeah i think for black as the pawns are
stuck on dark squares i can go for the
minority attack
yeah minority attack is when you have a
two on three situation
and you storm with uh the two
trying to do some weaknesses in the
three
thank you balubaloo
opponent probably wants to play this
which
it might be hard to stop
could respond with bishop bishop f4
i mean h5 with g5 because i want to keep
h file closed
oh
to do this i can't believe i'm almost a
twitch baby any interest in playing a
greco gambit amused very maybe or very
possibly
yeah i want to play e5 here
there's a cool looking move
fakes takes
i'll play e5
no time to calculate
so i'm i'm end game gamuting upon
to try and uh double these pawns and get
the rook in
oh it's probably a good move unless i
have this move
which almost works promise bishop g7 in
the end
so i guess rook f
f3 looks wrong
i gotta do it
oh
completely overlooked that okay i'm in
trouble now
16 months wow thanks for the awesome
content for the 16 months
yeah i'm in trouble
ah my pawn
please take it please yes let's go okay
i'm winning now
opponent took the bait
i was the only hope
actually it still might be a fight
because black has pawns but black is
probably crying now
um
yeah let's take and
just take and push the pawn
maybe do this hey eric let's peek today
i'm going to try and peek
first i have to stop these pawns
there we go
okay pawns are being tamed
it's scary but uh king is coming here
and yeah that was nice okay wow
oh that was a close one i could have
easily lost that
um
knight c5 was
very strong
i got to find position and then
black played well to actually
counter like stop my minority attack and
just
make progress on the king side
this bishop was strong
uh
but
yeah this uh
this oh no my pawn paid off
okay let's move on thank you tagi
ifting5
thanks so much five more people have
access to the talk emote
and thank you mvp at life for the 500
bits
so i want to make a notepad of every
opening that i played so game one was
hill billy
versus caro come on
okay so i'm gonna try and play a
different gambit every game
um i'll hold off from berserking
i know a lot of people want staffer
gambit so
uh i'll try wow it's a lot of talky
emotes
how many talking boots there are
okay uh ooh
okay i'm gonna play uh d5 and i'm gonna
play a reverse myth mora
which involves c6
and i might even after it takes i might
play reverse danish
which might be reckless but fun
okay
now i'm just making stuff up
i insist on the gambit
of this move
now maybe this move okay
so i've i'm down the pawn but i have
some
more active development e5 potential
prime 75
so if takes i take induce the pin take
away white's casting rights
and then take back
and if that wow wow
eric baiting opponents is super easy
barely an inconvenience
yeah it's one of my hobbies these days
this is getting spicy
i want to take and then
between a pawn
um
what else was there
i take on
i have this move g4
oh and then sack
uh
let's do it
yeah it reminds me of the baffinix
hemislav
where you take and then
this is probably objectively bad for a
block but it looks fun
there's prospects of getting a bishop to
f3
and
[Music]
yeah queen a4 is a move
this sentence contains exactly three
errors
three
oh three error oh
i pronounce that pretty well though
also i'm in some trouble here
uh because my things are falling
i'm
in this move no
and queen a4 was such a good move
whoa it's har krishnan gifting so many
subs
i have to focus though
thanks for all the gifted subs
i think i just play rook c8 and then cry
i'll be down on time down to peace
but i have a open file
dreaming of taking this bishop someday
thank you hari krishnan
lifting 10.
word francesco
yeah that's good move okay so we're
we're alleviating the pin
um if take side
if any tricky
wait what is this move
okay i have some trickies so this is a
a double attack against the queen
discovered attack against the bishop and
the skewer
along the c file
um and a potential outpost on d3 or f3
yeah that turned around really quickly
wow
can we get some wow wows again
oh we have to wait for the sub thing to
to finish
um so this was a
uh improvised
english
gambits or gamut against english
i just want to see this uh computer
graph
yeah
wow wow
eric baiting opponents is super easy
barely an inconvenience yeah i feel like
i'm going to be replaying that tts a lot
this stream
okay
looks like a fun roller
coaster nice
nice drop okay
okay undefeated
very dubious aggressive chest so far
yeah thanks to everyone who's been
subbing and gifting and cheering
our ph guy
yash nevadi
east charm
okay it's africab time
hopefully
okay i'm gonna play um this line
where i say oh no my oh
white's not going into anything
actually wait i have this move
is this just
better for black
so d4 is like an anti-stafford
i think white's already walking into
some pain
all right krishna
you just gift another 10 i think you did
unless i'm experiencing deja vu
wait i'm confused thanks for gifting
another 10.
also welcome back to pam
okay i think i'll gambit my night
yeah let's oh no my knight
but oh yes i'm forking stuff
very temporary
pork the point is after takes queen h4
and it's reminiscent of a reverse fried
liver
toggy gifting 10 thanks toggy
so much love
10 more people so many more people have
the tagi emote now
okay time to
punish white
i should calculate
queen g3 king d2
maybe i should just castle
it's castle
the rook wants to join the party
like when you have
three people at a party
you want to have more people
and then it becomes a bigger party
then order some pizza rookie it takes
where's the meat let's just maintain the
pin
he won
oh
[Music]
this king wants to leave the party
how do i invite the king back
i'll just bring more things to the party
okay so i'm still down the piece but
okay now the king
is on a light square
we'll start with this move threatening
the sneaky skewer
if a4 i think i'll play c5
because i want to open the c file get
all my pieces involved
incubicriz
incente
so opponent wants to play knight e3
i'll play c5
it's absolutely gifting too eric.
and we are going for more.love you heart
oh i love you too thanks so much
[Music]
so much hype much wow so much hype
oh the king wants to really just retire
uh
how do i stop it
oh there's a funny line
where i take
does it work it might work it is after
takes queen e4
type training takes a bishop f5
and now the king has to
return to the center
i appreciate the hype train bits
let's
play there's so many funny things i want
to do
almost works too
i want to play queen e193 it doesn't
quite work though
okay let's just play this and
is matt stafford your favorite qb
uh
oh is that a quarterback
if that's actually his name then yes of
course
okay so if takes takes i attack the
knight and threaten the pin
i'm also threatening the bishop
maybe threatening the um the fork
followed by the discovery followed by
the the wind of the queen
i have 26 seconds to try and convert
this
okay
doing some fancy tactics
oh i want to do okay let's just take
and push upon
i have to be aware of c4 and the battery
um i'll take
it takes i have f5
f4 at some point
i'm gonna say laser focused here there's
this move too
wow
like this
so oh no i'm getting fork skewered but i
have this move
for fork that was a wooden shield but a
failed wooden shield it was actually a
funny uh
like black or white was attacking
everything but it just didn't work
and now life is very good up the
exchange
the king is naked
and we'll go for the
the triple open vial mate
not quite
e5
or uh i wanted to finish the game with
g5 that was still pleasant though
we need a slow motion replay
for this uh
oh no
uh
i don't think i have
no it doesn't sound familiar
at least not knowingly
so slow motion replay wait
the bishop took my pawn
attacked everything
and pinned my queen to the king
xqc would be very impressed with this
but not all wooden shields
and good for the
for the person doing the wooden shield
this was a counter
like golden shield
okay
uh let's move on
what opening was that i was like auntie
stafford
auntie stafford oh no my knight
on gambit thing
okay
so top 50
every game has been kind of fun
i guess the second game i won in like 13
moves
but the first and most recent game where
long fights
okay new gambit what to play
i'll play a smith mora
ooh
i insist on speaking
broke two months ago frown
oh no your
streak i insist on smith mora
i will i just want to smith mora i'll
play e5
let's take my pawn
opponents not behaving just take my pawn
at some point i'll take back i have i've
tried so hard but
what to do
takes takes
i'm actually not sure what to do here
maybe i'll take and play bishop g3
still waiting for them to take my pawn
ah they're not taking it
okay last chance take my pawn
at least i have the h file now
my pawns have been like this for most of
the game
there we go okay
it's finally a gambit
so i have uh
an h file
i have some development opponent
unexpectedly bond clouding
what is king e7
it's a funny move
i plan this together another pawn
at him rosen that bits you are playing
over and over are from those pitch
meetings
oh wait really
oh the wow wow wow
i guess i didn't
realize
the b4 is annoying
maybe i'll play this move
restricting the knight
offering the trade
i still want to play this in this
yeah so now now i'm attacking the knight
and the pawn
and now i have the oh it's a pork it's a
pin plus a fork
one of the tastiest tactics
opponent proceeds to bond cloud even
more
now i could take the queen but i'm
trying to
imagine some castling queenside with
mate
there's e5 unfortunately let's just take
and uh we'll enjoy
position okay
uh
yeah i mean after king e7 this this idea
immediately came to mind
um i thought it would only be a fantasy
until it became
reality okay so that was a smith mora
myth mora
kind of
okay um i haven't had a true stafford
yet so
i'll try and get a true staff right now
you know you want to
yes okay
so after grammar time
this time accepted oh opponent gives
back the pawn straight away
so this is a counter gambit
at some point i might want to counter
counter gambit
bishop d2 i take on d4
yeah this is already very unpleasant for
whites i went upon
the king open
i guess i'm forced to trade queens i
have this move
just defending
if takes like a pinned but then i can
castle with check
wow
i would like to keep queens on the board
somehow
uh there's this move which might just
win
yeah attacking everything
painful game for white
hey it's pam what's up pam
lifting five thanks so much
even after life train really appreciate
that
have this move now
oh no my
oh actually that would be bad
[Music]
i don't want to trade queens but
probably should
i'm just taking
[Music]
to be a little bit careful
so if i take there's
hi eric just wanted to say that your
youtube videos are not only entertaining
but they have helped me become better at
chess oh that's so kind
thank you
that's great to hear one yeah
really rex
okay so i have rock f2 here
um up two pawns
yeah this this opening started just
staff or gambit down a pawn but
opponent was counter generous
i have this move
and now
ooh
i'll play f5 so i'm threatening the rook
but also threatening rook c2
if this i made if this side
probably just taken with the bishop
okay that was pleasant
so a lot of these games i'm winning like
relatively quickly
nice miniatures
okay
uh that was stafford
gambit meets counter gambit
the five games so far
five different kind of strange garbage
to catch many streams since the birth of
my son could you play the tennis and
gambit at some point this stream ps
thanks for the amazing content yeah
let's play tennyson
so if d5 i'll play yeah tennis and
gambit that was very good timing
your wish is my command
my command is your wish please play this
okay so we have a
tennyson where wait does this work
big bishop no it doesn't work
tennyson where black is avoiding the
traps i'll try and play aggressively
here
also happy belated birthday to your son
i assume it's like his zeroth birthday
right
um
[Music]
i want to play this move provoke e5 and
then just move back
ooh okay this knight's not defended now
can i punish black this move this move
this move looks fun
now there's a pin
it's attacked twice
if queen defends
ooh
wow
okay
as a nice gambit recommendation tennis
and gambit
looks like
looks like this is winning
after just 11 moves
point is after takes i check and win the
queen or i
win one of these things
i didn't want to take on c7 immediately
because
uh
i wouldn't be mating
black's gonna fight on
understandably so
kind of want to play castling queenside
although castling kingside is probably
more responsible
the question is can i save the night
might be difficult
trade
yeah let's just trade
like i'm up a full rook here so
[Music]
i could desperado
i think i'll play this move idea after
it takes
i start getting initiative
might still pinned
life is still good
thank you space ops wahoo six months
wahoo
the risk is i'm aligning my stuff so
there's potential companies i want to
hear what authorshnap sounds like on tt
uh what to do here
there's this move
play this move
i'm asking to get discovered skewered
but after which there should be enough
counter attacks between this or
this stuff
you have been giving me 12 months of
entertainment thanks a scotch or a
buddha pest gambit would be good
yeah i'll keep those in mind
i don't think i've encountered d4 yet
this uh the stream
it's bound to happen eventually
oh this tournament is only
for some reason i thought it was three
hours long
it's only uh
i guess two hours total
or hour and a half total
okay what to do here
right queen g4
maybe just this move
safety first
if i defend i also pressure the bishop
um
defend some more
yeah gotta move a little bit quicker
here
getting the queen
ac3
or
hitting this pawn now
if we end up trading then i'll be
threatening b6
and pinning stuff finding this now
i don't think the queen has a square to
keep the knight defended
there's bishop c3 but rook c1
yeah it's a very nice kabob along with a
pin
really no counter attacks
f2 is covered
okay that was pleasant
i got low on time but uh
position was good
that was a fun one kindness and grab it
played super aggressively it paid off
um
yeah so this is just a 90 minute
tournament
i was game six anderson gambit
um i'll play e4 again hoping for a
french so i can play an ortho snap
oh this time i'll play a scotch gambit
will you do 24-hour stream on friday
after nine days
uh
after wait after nine days
um probably not anytime soon but maybe
maybe some friday in the future
opponents declining the gambit i'm going
to play um
in the style of
anziani
so this is a nice trap after queen e2 if
black plays this or this i on poissant
and the knight's not defended and the
pawn landing on one of these squares
prevents queen e7
so
locks in trouble there's knight c5 and
then i take and then
knight gets kicked around
oh i think this is the best line though
for black
i'll take threatening f3
opponent is kind of counter
gambiting but
this should still be good for lights
because i still have my pawn here
takes takes high pressure the knights
and i mean rookie 8
now i have this move
i still have my pawn here
i think i'll take on g7 soon and
enjoy
the nakedness of box
king maybe castling queenside
bishop e2
[Music]
to do this
maybe castling kingside
exchange
i like to keep f2 defended
and the plan is to lift the rook over
and keep initiative
okay preparing rook g3
so i tried to gambit this game but i'm
the one up a pawn
question is how to proceed
maybe bishop c4
queen d4
i'll start with this
i want to play this eventually
hey it's adfast oh maybe i'll try and
play a traxler at some point
i track sorry budapest
a lot of classic gambits i want to
check off the bucket list
okay i think f3 is called for eventually
or even f4
f4 f5 could be interesting
and black definitely has compensation
here though
this move
oh
i'm losing maybe not
moving on to the pawn i also unpin the f
pawn so
probably now threatening to take
if rook c2 i think i just take and
when f2 doesn't hurt me too much
interesting
you don't know what to do here
give me this move
it's strange to put the rook here that i
just want to take upon
if rook here i might even play f4 first
this takes his rook g8
which i don't want to deal with
yeah i got to be careful here
turning into a bullet game
with rook g8 i play this or even this
probably queenie
actually i don't know
just move back
it's equal material
position is getting spicier
but the king side's safe
maybe each word some point
really cementing the rook
push the pass pawn
the push and baby
defend
also this move
this moves
trickier oh no my pawn
[Music]
oh no my pawn
let's take
it
the pawn's always poisonous
running this now
f5 was nice because it supports this and
defends this
now it's a mating attack oh no my rook
where's my mate
where's my mate
there's my mate
okay
that's a fun game
what does leech house call this
opening
the goring
oh that was a goring gambit i tried to
play scotch gamut
the two are very similar
boring
okay
let's move on
uh i was actually in control like the
whole game
um
okay top ten sixth place
make a running to try and win this
tournament
i'm not uh
i'm not berserking too much
winning a game
here we go
oh let's play a walrus there's not too
many gamuts i can play against knight f3
but the walrus is one of them
so this could actually transpose to a
stafford
if y plays e4
if g3 then this looks fun
now queen d5 and white has to either
play this or this or this
yeah this already looks
really fun
the g3 is very tender
king f2 or rg1 coming
and
the thing is e4 is coming so
[Music]
be wise in the way i proceed
i'll start with this
on an offer to draw
no draw if this i play this
i want to play f5 just want to open
files before white
develops anything
these pawns are
they're frowning from my perspective
from mike's perspective they were
smiling but
now the pawns are
in more shambles
i could castle
just castle here
i guess i just castle
oh no my bishop
i'm threatening maiden two
so white needs to be careful
if rook f1 i take and uh bring the other
rook to f8
yeah this is a very very pleasant walrus
these pieces are feeling left out
oh there's a funny line uh takes or cafe
queen g1 bishop h3
to deflect the king away
wow
e3
oh i can just take the thing
[Music]
and then be up a piece
yeah i can choose which bishop i want to
take
i think i'll take this thing
but then knight d2
[Music]
i'll take this thing
i keep the pin
and then probably threaten this
although
maybe i can start with this or not okay
so that was a walrus
and these gambits are working out well
let's proceed thank you eric the sailor
subbing with prime it's a new prime sub
we have looxius 14
solving with prime for eight months
um and thanks to everyone who maybe i
didn't acknowledge
i have been focusing more on the games
trying to
keep the quality high
um
i still want an ortho schnapp
okay let's play a wing gambit i played i
tried to play the mora earlier
wow d5
i feel like i've seen this at some point
i think i'll play this and
um insist on gabbing
what is going on here bishop b2
i didn't want to run into this and get
forked
okay
it's officially a gambit
lock finally took
and now i'm trying to induce taking so
my knight can develop
there's a funny line takes takes a6 i
still play knight b5
knight c6 is a fine move i'll play
bishop e2
idea being if takes takes takes there's
takes a d4
so this is resembling a french
uh that's a good move
now it's time to take
and then get the pawn here thank you to
zen fortitude gifting five
appreciate that
yeah so now this bishop looks kind of
ridiculous but the idea is to
play this and get my knight in
with a6 i still play knight b5
that's a fine move
i'll play
this move run the knight
and just castle this could be more
positional
there's some positional compensation
because
black no longer has c5
still trying to exploit my pawn
oh isn't that uh that's like beetle
lyrics right
is a song from the beatles
what day is it on friday next week
uh friday right
unless it's thursday on friday next week
oh it's a good move
play this move
no let's not play that move
ah what do i do
if this move maybe
i don't want to
get hurt too much
let's play this move so i'm grabbing
some exchange
oh i'm in trouble though
[Music]
wow they take
okay let's take this way i'm still in
trouble
[Music]
x6 takes
i don't really want to trade queens
but i kind of have to
yeah it's not pleasant
oh no i've gammeted too much
and my knights just trapped the smooth
maybe
i had to stop rook c8
it takes i have this mesopotamia
oh welcome back to mesopotamia
and squishy hercules
yeah i'm feeling the pain
treat every gambit as a blunder
uh that's not that's not what you're
supposed to do
that's kind of what i'm doing do you
like rose and trenter and oxo gambits
oh i've heard of those
yeah the rosen shredder
it's so painful
[Music]
my thing is so sad
my time
let's believe
getting this now
for this
[Music]
yeah this is really bad
i do
there's no still matrix either
i got mated okay
oh
okay so i lost my first game the wing
gambit
has been defeated
in gambit vs sicilian
oh no my
my rating kind of
okay we'll try and rebound with more
gambits
nobody's working though
um if d4 i'll go for a buddha pass if e4
what happened i played yes oh i guess
i'll build it i'm gonna play the
o'sullivan or scandi maybe
i'll play whatever this is
uh
i guess i can take
no let's treat this as a no
wait
let's take i'll be down the pond
um
but there's some some diagonal
[Music]
some g-file
[Music]
okay
you're already getting the gambit style
compensation winning material now
running this
and the knights pin too also threatening
this
oh this would be a
nasty fork
here we go
i'm winning something here if this i
fork if this side fork
this side went upon
and also kind of fork
i'll lift the rook
do i forgot queens could move from far
distances
okay
i have to treat that as
as a gambit i guess
ah my pawn
i've induced white's queen into the
corner and now the queen's not here to
defend my may threat
wow it's a fancy move
play this
oh no
okay quindy it was missed
there we go
that was a nice kind of
taste of my opponent's medicine my
opponent moved into my corners
and i moved into the opponent's corner
okay
what was that opening that was like an
alakan
alakine
weird thing
i can't spell
friday next week is 3rd of september
oh it's true
[Music]
wait that's my
birthday i think i was also born on a
friday
i wonder how often that happens
probably one and seven
wait really my birthday is coming up
okay playing mexi let's play
oh let's play this um
stuff
not really a gambit but
at some point i'll sock stuff
uh
like this
yeah so my idea is to play
d4
okay now i'm gammating
idea to do fun things
wow so if here
let's play this
yeah sometimes it's hard to gamut
against g6 lines
but uh trying to make this oh no my
bishop but
black doesn't get forked
trying to make this work
i am ready to take back the pawn if
black doesn't take
wow
take on f7
that looks too much fun let's take
black was expecting it
so now i'm down a piece
but it's just heating up
letting the pawn
forking doesn't work
unfortunately it's a good move i have c4
oh no my pawn
if takes i fork
okay here i fork
i don't know what just happened but
something happened
life goes on
so i have broken two pawns for two
nights
an interesting material imbalance
the king f1 first didn't want to get
checked
good move
and difficult position of this move
though
i'll win the pawn
once bishop c3 but then this move
[Music]
check
be very careful here
it's almost made
not quite
hey let's go i went on time and i was
winning in the final position too
that was a weird game
what opening was that i was like modern
um
reckless how do i spell reckless
reckless play against modern
is it with a w
i don't think it is unless it is
unless both spellings are correct
okay
move on
wow i'm in second place
i guess i double berserked one
i'll only berserk if my opponent
berserks
oh it's a silent k
no w okay good
okay nobody's working so i played e5
earlier the walrus now i'll play g5
which is
i guess now decline with b4
uh what is this
let's make things weird
attack upon
oh no my knight
what is this opening
this funniest opening i've ever had
probably
my bishop's getting trapped
which isn't so funny
a6
i treat every blunder as a gambit
take and win a two
what is this position likes playing
fisher random
my rook is my only developed piece
uh
let's develop a knight
i don't want my rook to get trapped
though
even though it's probably about to get
trapped
bishop east actually let's play
play c6 defend
ooh fancy move
i have f or knight f6
there's not too many moves here let's
play this
this is such a weird position
i've broken two pawns for knight in
bishop
similar material imbalance compared to
the last game
um
[Music]
i could take with pawn but then bishop
g5
if i take with queen
that's probably the best approach
i don't mind the queen trade
if i get forked i take the queen
this rook is actually well placed
putting constant pressure on the seven
or on the second
maybe i'll play this move
pressuring the knight
hmm
i can take and play rook a1
and after rook a1 knight b3 i take take
rook b1 wins a piece i think
this pawn is clutch because after knight
b3 takes take never mind
king d1 is probably a good move
maybe this move
as if oh i just lost a pawn
or did i have b6 coming
i'll try and win this pawn
wow
reserve my knight
objectively i'm probably worse here but
it's still interesting
my rook's still active things are pinned
now f2 is attached
light's restricted
like a castle but the king is better
in the center
so the other rook wants to join the
party
here's this move
yeah the rook wants to come in
if night here
[Music]
my brook is almost trapped
oh no
how'd that happen
oh how that happened
i'm down on time too
[Music]
such an awkward square for the rook
f3 is a good move too play g3 and
this and rook g8
the pawn
so i want to play
yeah i want to play this pin the bishop
and then get my rook out of here
okay here we
go um
pressure everything
28 seconds
okay now i'm winning
almost everything
except only in the night
a funny move
oh that saves everything
well played
i have to i could have taken the knight
i think
maybe i'm still winning something
e5
yeah d4 is coming
and my epoch didn't move for so long
running this now
getting this
uh oh
yeah
l1 f3
bye
let's go
okay
let's go
i actually had a very similar position
a few years ago
in a tournament game and i won in the
same fashion
it was dead drawn bishop and pond vs
rook
and my opponent uh somehow found a way
to get mated
um that's why you should play on and not
flag
what opening was that
oh that was
uh it was this game
oh it's such a funny game
there's no way like this position's ever
been played like
on move three i think that's completely
new position
[Music]
oh wow wait let's see uh leches database
so b4 has been played before
oh d4 was a novelty and then then it
just got crazy
okay
uh oh this graph let's move on
so
[Music]
that was
knight f3 g5 leads to insanity
so i'm top five
might be hard to win this tournament but
let's still try and keep gamuting
yeah hello to gory hello to everyone
watching
for those just joining i'm playing the
daily super blitz arena
i'm trying to play a different gambit
every single game
um
i'll play a d4 gamut
uh let's play g4
yeah i think they call this the steinitz
or rubenstein
named after one of the
og chess players
um
i don't know what i'm doing here
play this move
be h3 coming
okay i could take
let's take
make things
spicy
now knight of three
taking was probably the wrong decision
what to do
please ignore this and focus on the game
okay i'm focusing focus time
getting a knight if this i want to play
e6 eventually but
lock's probably going to beat me to it
that doesn't scare me
okay now i want to play king f1
also knight h4
um
e6 is coming unless i play okay e6 time
i'm gabbing some more
because i i just didn't want the things
to defend the things
in this way i might be able to take and
actually get away with it
the bishop has a hard time taking back
there's that move yeah
maybe like d4
there's a funny line takes takes takes
takes takes takes
oh but i take on h8
and then win everything
so that would be pleasant
oh please do it
b4 is interesting
hmm
you take the knight
i'll take the knight in
castle queenside
didn't spend too much time here
yeah so i just calculated uh rook b rook
g1
i think is a key move
well i have to generate initiative
quickly wow castling queen sign
uh
now i'll put the rook here
pressure the bishop
it's hard to actually attack on the
queen side
e4 always runs into this queen e3 check
maybe
start with
start with queen f4
i do this in this
i can take
like queen h4
you need to swing back over
e7 is also tender
preventing queen f4
i don't want to trade queens
e5
um
always play king b1 i guess
make luft
oh fancy move
this is so confusing i have no time
i just want to
do things with my
things
this and this
if this i play this
33 seconds to a minute
it does look more fun because this king
is much more exposed
it can
move over
good thing i made luft
just have to watch out for this bishop
being unleashed
the a4
place a5a6
[Music]
uh wow
i'm meeting i'm meeting let's go
only legal move
okay it worked out what a game
the opening was oh that was uh
yeah what is the name of this
this is called the
oh the gibbons widen hagen
okay i didn't know that had an actual
name
gibbons widening hagen
that's a cool name
let's move on
so
10 points are the first whoa it's jw
content has helped me develop
tremendously thanks so much thanks for
being you
oh that's so kind thanks for being you
being so generous
okay what to play let's play um
e5
at this point i'm just making up gambits
uh
b4 counter
the counter polish or orangutan
i guess i'll play e5
try and follow some opening principles
and take a free pawn
i guess it's just a trade
look at this and then take with rook and
then swing the rook over how about
this looks fun
yeah
oh i'm having too much fun in this
tournament
now push idea to target g2
[Music]
i also want to play this this and be
sneaky along the diagonal
uh neither four is coming
oh actually no knight of four i take
now maybe threatening this move oh this
is so much fun
i should probably develop my king side
someday
f4 is probably a good move
to do this
i want to play queen eight but then
queen d5
kind of ruins my fun
i mean this is kind of the
natural continuation
there's also rook d6
i think i'll play no rookie 6.84
i'll start with this
f5 then this
some idea also queen h4
oh no my knight
when it's not giving in though
give me this move
now this move what is going on
attacking double attacking the queen
there's no queen e5 check
everything's hanging
okay so i won the queen but i'm losing a
knight
white's gonna have
oh
white is being generous
now it's getting mated
actually is it so simple
depends what white does
yeah now i have this move
and probably just win the night
i also have this move oh this fancy move
let's win the night first
bishop is trapped
rook is almost trapped okay that was a
funny game
so what does leachates call b5
oh the the yanish gambit
that's also a gamut against a spanish
that was a funny game
got some rook lifting in
okay
in third place
so 18 minutes less than 18 minutes left
trying to close in on first
it's doable
but there's an im who's berserk winning
a lot of games
i lost her streak
i just want to keep playing fun dubious
gambits
okay playing kojnay
oh
i feel like i've run out of gambits
against this maybe i'll start with this
and
again go for
let's play a wing reverse wing gabbat
pretty sure susan polgar didn't teach
these openings
ha ha yeah
oh can't imagine how
you would react to this play
okay uh
let's just develop let's uh accelerate
development
and
try and justify the fact i'm down upon
we'll try and open the center
i mean white is very underdeveloped
stick with queen
stick with
stick with bishop yeah white has nothing
developed until now
okay i'll gamble this pawn because why
not
opponents being wise
complete development
and
go for this
i'm gonna try and get some attack in
and squeeze white on the queen side
eventually i do want to play this move
yeah this is actually a problem
i want to play this but then e4
if i play e4 right now
[Music]
it doesn't work at all
so maybe this move
not what i want but
keeps things defended now i have the
square to work with
so some idea a4 bishop b3
good move
i'll have to take
i mean there's night
let's try this
yeah just trying to create some
imbalance
and now there's some plan c5 bishop here
and then eventually mate
being very optimistic
also some plan a5 and then lift the rook
and then later c5 bishop c7
maybe bishop b3
also plans with f5
this move's coming
it's hard to stop
as i just allow it
take
okay five
okay another rook lifting
moment
f4 might be coming
i can't look rook lift
anywhere f4 would control like all the
squares
there's a funny idea
if white plays f4
never mind
maybe it's time for f5
yeah because i want this work involved
so it would be very nice if i place f4
it takes takes and then i
i fork discover win everything
but that's not happening
probably don't want a queen trade
hitting the pawn
pieces actually have nice harmony
everything's defended here
only down the pawn up some time
i might even want to lift the other rook
doing a lot of rook lifting
only swear for the queen is b7
queen was almost trapped
not quite
let's take
opening the file it takes and there's
some potential for
discoveries yeah f3
the move white wants to play but gets
punished punished with d3
um
[Music]
yeah unfortunately my pawn
is perished
i think i'm gonna win on time though
oh it's emo only mode
someone redeemed something i think
um
[Music]
let's show you the pair of rooks
here we go
okay one on time
what gambit was that
i was like in english
oh that was a
reverse
reverse wing
gambit versus english okay
uh let's preserve and let's play let's
play a black mardemer
wait black mardemer
is f3 eventually
okay black more dimmer time
i'm playing the person in first place
too so
uh we'll see how this goes
i'm down upon so
off to an expected start
i'm getting some
[Music]
compensation
keeping the pressure open f-file
i kind of want to play this move
also maybe just this move
making things
crowded
oh no my bishop
not sure how sound this is but
it looks fun
white no longer has an h-pawn
uh
that's actually a good move
maybe this
working oh no my pawn now i'm
threatening this and this
[Music]
probably have to take
it's getting weird
is going on b1
oh no i'm getting forked
oh a point wants to pork me did this
move
am i down how am i down a piece
oh i sucked a piece earlier oops
down the piece here
try and recover
putting stuff
in the corner
[Music]
oh no
you don't see it please how they saw it
how bad is this
it's kind of bad
oh it's tilting
okay
failed plaquemine
okay that was my second loss of the
tournament
still hope though do i try and win the
tournament by berserking the rest of my
games
maybe i do
yeah opponent played fast that game and
found knight g3
my queen unfortunately got trapped
i like my position too just a bit too
slow
[Music]
okay
tilt berserking
uh let's play in england
play one of these
oh my knight oh no
actually with the pawn in e4 it might be
different
okay opponent doesn't take it though
i think white could have taken and
played king e2 bishop g4 knight f3 but
okay
not happening
so playing
some gambit style
oh no my bishop
a typical fishing pole trap
now i probably want to sack and have fun
i'm trying to win as quickly as possible
[Music]
let's take that
oh
take maybe
take with bishop okay so
this could be a longer grind
but still trying to attack
getting stuff
taken
in some
things there's bishop seven king here
now probably castling
yeah the position was very sus earlier
but uh
now it's good up upon
uh going in for the kill
[Music]
just have to make sure white doesn't
have enough counter play
oh it's a windmill
i have mates
oh this is a nice mate here here
and then mate
and white had e4 but okay let's move on
so
still within range i need to get in like
two more games maybe
oh it's probably
this robert
no
robert's not from cuba
uh oh let's keep playing gambits
okay gambit declined
uh
playing whatever this is
that's risky to do against the player
like this but
try and still be aggressive
hey aaron clay there's a funny line
rosen oh
[Music]
always looking for funny lines
take an
in
bring the queen to the game
push upon
i had to watch out for this move but i
think it's okay
trying to play like alpha zero
so c5 is always met with queen d5
oh
fancy
with a rook
if i took with bishop there is a pork so
i had to be careful there
okay pressuring the knight
wow take that
and to calculate this and this
go for it
so there's looming potential
oh do i suck
i think i got a sack if i want to win
quickly
this could really backfire but it's
still interesting
idea king d2 rook g1
might be a little bit slow but
we'll find out soon
go down a minute
oh i played
with this move
i have to play this move
i do this and this
it's hard to solve rook g2
this is probably last game that counts
for the tournament
[Music]
inbox the material here
the threatening queen jeter rook g7
two pawns
there we go
there we go
classic end game
made is coming
got the berserking points too
yeah there's no defense these pawns are
irrelevant
okay let's go
just enough time thank you gary
yeah oh opponent rage quit
but it'll account for the tournament
pairings are probably closed anyway so
it's okay
i can claim victory
two seconds before my opponent flags
oh never mind
i'll draw
or resign wait if i try clicking call
draw and then it switched to resign
that would have been tragic
but hey okay i finished with a win
bearings are closed i finish in fifth
didn't quite finish in the top
up first place but that was a fun
tournament
um
i don't know what my last
i think that was game
18. that was like an attempted
attempted gibbons something something
um
i have to go back and see what the other
game was
i think i'll put this whole tournament
on youtube whoa it's sonya lang thank
you sonya lane
with a five five five
quadruple five
five five five five bits
thanks so much
that's so kind
um
yeah that was really fun i i did try to
play a different gambit every game
and even in games where my opponent
declined gambits i tried to insist on
gamuting
led to just some really
probably unsound dubious but uh
enjoyable chess
so
yeah this goes on youtube
thanks for watching let me know if you
made it this far
if you made it this far
comment below your your favorite gambit
actually about to hit a half a million
subscribers on youtube so
once i do i'll have a 12 hour stream